[Music]
perfect way to start Oprah this is a big
week for her first she's here at the
table that's lucky you know and then
she's going on Stephen Colbert tonight
but it's a really big week the highly
anticipated new movie wrinkle in time if
you heard about it it hits theaters
nationwide on Friday we'll talk to her
about her role as mrs. which later in
the broadcast and for Sunday 60 minutes
Oprah traveled to Milwaukee that's where
she grew up to learn about a
revolutionary approach in the city to
childhood trauma she talked to dr. Bruce
Perry he's the world's leading expert on
early trauma he's treated survivors of
high-profile events like the Columbine
shooting here's a preview of Oprah's
report that very same sensitivity that
makes you able to learn language just
like that as a little infant makes you
highly vulnerable to chaos threat
inconsistency on priorities violence and
so children are much more sensitive to
developmental trauma than adults so if
your child who's raised in a nurturing
and well-cared-for environment you're
more likely to have a well-wired brain
correct and if you were a child who's
raised in an environment of chaos of
uncertainty of violence of neglect you
are being wired differently differently
and and typically in a way that makes
you more vulnerable kids that grow up
like that have much higher rates of risk
for mental health problems much higher
rates of risk for doing poorly in school
for just functioning in the world
exactly we are pleased to welcome listen
she's an actress philanthropist media
mogul but she's also a 60-minute special
contributor we like saying that I am
Oprah's beckon studio 57 the reason why
I'm so excited about this story is
because I know you were excited you took
it to 60 minutes you have to decide as a
matter of fact when we were doing the
critical review of the pieces because
you know you go through the process with
Jeff acre and Jeff decides whether it's
ready or not and I said to them in the
room that this is the reason why I came
to 60 minutes I'm always looking for the
deeper meaning this story is so in
important to me and I believe to our
culture but if I could dance on the
tabletops right now to get people to pay
attention to it I would it has
definitively changed the way I see
people in the world and it has
definitively changed the way I will now
be operating my school in South Africa
and going forward any philanthropic
efforts that I'm engaged in because it's
huge for you to say that it's huge if I
could be a dancing emoji about it I
would because I think it's that
important to our culture and it's
changed your view from what to what well
what I recognize is is that a lot of
NGOs
a lot of people who are working in
philanthropic world who are trying to
help disadvantaged challenged people
from you know backgrounds that have been
disenfranchised are working on the wrong
thing and unless you fix the trauma that
has caused people to be the way they are
literally change the way brains operate
if you're in a chaotic environment as a
child unless you fix the trauma you're
working on the wrong thing so for
instance you have job programs and
training programs and all of that stuff
that we've been doing for years but if
you don't fix the hole in the soul the
thing that neat that is where the wounds
started you you're working at the wrong
things so it's changed the way operate
my school we've now become as a result
of this piece that I did on 60 minutes I
went back to my board and said hey we've
been doing it all wrong we need to be a
trauma-informed care institution when
child welfare agency in Milwaukee said
that they even changed their approach to
a child instead of what's wrong with you
- what happened I will have to say
beyond that is that that was the life
changing question that that responded
that that my whole my whole senses
responded to see we go through life and
we see kids who are misbehaving you
juvenile delinquents we label them and
really the question that we should be
asking is not what's wrong with that
child but what happened to that child
and then having the resources to be able
to address what happened to you the most
important question you can ask of
anybody which is what I now say
even for the parkland shooting they said
what's the matter with that kid
I say what happened to that child it's a
personal story for you
number one it's in Milwaukee where you
were raised yeah certainly suffered
trauma there you weren't physically
abused in your home but you've talked
very candidly about it I got enough
weapons to call it we just did call it
physical yeah it would be but you've
certainly been very candid about the
sexual abuse and a lot of these kids
suffer from PTSD
I'm Marvel Oprah that the environment
you grew up in that you don't seem to
have suffered from people this is are
you rethinking that no I'm not no I
definitely do not have Petey okay
I definitely so and the reason I didn't
because I asked Bruce Perry this
question who's head of the trial child
trauma Institute how comes some kids
like myself raised in chaotic
environments turn out to be okay and
it's it's directly proportional to the
relationships so he was saying for me
for instance it was school I found my
refuge in school I found my place in
school from teachers so everybody needs
somebody growing up that says I believe
in you you're okay
things are gonna be all right and that
can be a teacher that can be a coach
that could be somebody in Sunday school
you know and great somebody who loved
you somebody who loved you somewhere is
the key to this building the emotional
structure that resilience and grit that
you need that that's what needs to be
you can't build resilience in grit if
there's a big hole in your soul but I
mean is that what you teach have to
build in those who have gone absolutely
but you are what happens is you have to
see this is what happened to me this is
why I behave the way I do this is why I
have such a short anger response and
this is why I can't I can't concentrate
this is why it's hard for me to keep a
job this is what and now that I
understand it it's not an excuse it's
just an explanation oh well now I know
why I behaved that way it's fantastic
no I mean I've never seen you as excited
as you were after you did after you tape
that and I've done a lot of stories of
my lifetime but I think this is the key
and I'm really excited that 60 minutes
was able to do it and that you know they
allowed me to do it it's gonna be a
game-changer really I think it could be
a game-changer I just want people to
hear it I want to you know dance on the
tabletops lose so did you
well succeed did you have to convince
well if fresh you know Jeff answer yeah
Jeff is like wow so Joe let me see the
story here and Rome Hartman the producer
we came back a couple of times and and
when finally faker said mister faker but
I think I think I see a story here
oh that's how it got done Oprah's gonna
stay around for another segment we're
gonna talk about that was she's
promoting 60 minutes of course but she's
also going to talk about wrinkle in time
and we're gonna talk to her about the
presidency we're gonna go there oh
you're not as we are we are gonna go
there Oprah on Dickerson has lots of
questions dig in deep she's putting it
on me yes I'm John Dickerson won't let
it go she won't let it go a lot of
people won't over let it go I'm not the
only one go let it go